[Musique]
e
il était une fois une moment dieu avec
son petit dieu dit moment est ce que tu
me donne la permission de faire un monde
tu as fini tes devoirs ouais là c'est
bon tu peux le petit dieu prix d'une
ardoise des craies de couleur et semi de
faire le monde que le soleil soit le
monsieur est la lune
nadal est il dit dans une petite fille
qu'on appela la petite aurore ensuite le
petit dieu créa les plantes qui poussent
sur la terre et les algues puis il créa
les bêtes qui marche celle qui rampent
celle qui nagent et celles qui veulent
[Musique]
ensuite il créa l'homme qui est le plus
intelligent des animaux de la terre
et quand il lui fait tout cela le ter
était remplie on y allait tous vides qui
veut habiter le ciel tout le monde
entend dit à l'exception du petit cochon
qui était occupé à manger des glands de
chênes
car le petit cochon et si gourmand quand
il mange n'entend rien et tous ceux qui
voulaient habiter le ciel vaart à
l'appel du petit dieu il avait le bélier
le taureau et le lion il y avait le
scorpion et le crabe qu'on appelle le
cancer il y avait la chèvre qu'on
appelle capricorne
il y avait des poissons il y avait les
200 tort et il y avait les deux jours
c'est une jeune fille qu'on appelle la
vierge alors le petit dieu les prix les
uns après les autres et les clous à sur
la voûte céleste
à l'aide de ces gros clous d'argent
qu'on appelle les étoiles à c'est très
joli tout ça mais moi quand je me levais
je vais les payer ses frais j'y avais
pas pensé
et dans ce cas c'est simple chaque matin
la petite aurore se lèvera vents et des
courants les habitants du ciel et chaque
soir quand il sera à coucher elle les
remettre en place
ainsi fut fait c'est pourquoi chaque
matin les étoiles disparaissent pour ne
revenir qu'à la nuit tombée
et bien moi alors pourquoi est-ce que
j'habite pas le ciel moi aussi pourquoi
tu ne vas pas demander qu'est ce que tu
faisais quand j'ai appelé des
volontaires crois que je mange des
glands de chênes à tapis pour toi vieux
monsieur le petit dieu trouvez moi une
petite place du temps aux autres de se
ré il ya plus de place qu'une fois bien
je veux aller au siège social
ce bien quand même pas tout le monde
mauvais je vais me venger
ma pauvre petit taureau cette huile
oracle se lever avant le jour pour
arracher des clous moi ça me révolte
c'est plutôt amusant ce travail qui sait
si tu voulais je montre avec toi je
t'aiderai quand on travaille la fois ci
il n'y a que sa porte c'est un plaisir
assez merveilleux je vais deux fois plus
vite que d'habitude
merci petit cochon dorian thorium petits
cochons qu'est ce que tu fais de l'aube
jusqu'à midi elle parcouru l'asie mais
nul n'y avait vu le petit cochon 2010 à
4 heures elle parcouru l'afrique et
après 4 heures elle parcouru l'europe
cependant le petit cochon se sachant
poursuivis s'était réfugié en france à
paris au 69 de la rue broca c'était une
épicerie buvette qui appartenait à papa
saïd ces deux dernières filles malika et
rachid a gardé la boutique sauvez moi je
vous en prie le petite aurore me court
après elle veut me tuer pour manger un
passif sinon qu'est ce que l'état
alors si on me demande vous m'avez pas
vu un c compris d'accord la petite
aurore vous rencontrer sans doute une
histoire à dormir debout au sujet d'une
toile que j'aurais mangé ce complètement
absurde
pourquoi readily comme valls sur i télé
qu'il nous parlait on a dit non
bonjour mademoiselle est ce que par
hasard vous n'auriez pas vu un petit
cochon rose exactement n'avait pas vu si
vous ne l'avez pas vu comment savez vous
qu'il est lumineux c'est parce qu'il a
osé vous êtes bien sûr de ne pas avoir
vu ses petits cochons la journée
finissait c'était l'heure où la petite
aurore devait remettre en place les
habitants du ciel étoilé
tu as pris mon étoile paix de l'ua pour
demander doit le bonheur mais bien
qu'est ce qui se passe bien ce n'est pas
malin à présent il va falloir me dire à
ton père à ces malades
le petit cochon est sûrement chez papa
said we que l'on me donne mon grand
manteau noir mon chapeau noir mon
écharpe noirmont basque loire et mes
lunettes mois et givet ns et pour
monsieur ce sera rien je voudrais vous
parler je suis le soleil jeudi à
chercher le petit cochon qui a mangé
l'étoile polaire
qu'est ce que vous me racontez ya pas de
petit cochon ici et moi je suis sûr
qu'il y ait ce sont vos enfants qu'ils
ont fait en paix vous avez eu un petit
cochon oui un petit cochon pas une
hypothèse bien sûr vous êtes sourbes un
petit cochon tout vert voilà la prem
qu'est ce que ça veut dire cacher un
petit cochon chez moi il est ici lynchez
moi
lâchez moi je veux rester ici tu verras
tu voudras mais moi je veux les toiles
que l'étoile jeu jamais fait de toi ne
parle pas tant un menteur et cache là
et plus le temps n'attend employons les
grands moyens
monsieur saïd avez vous un couteau pour
ta punition
puisque tu aimes tant les choses qui
brillent tu sera changé en tirelire tu
garderas cette fente dans ton dos
monsieur saïd ighli sera les pourboires
est une sera délivrée que quand tu seras
pelade ce papa ça il n'oublie jamais ce
qui s'est fait pour voir dans la fente
mais comme les enfants viennent y puiser
je ne dis pas tous les jours que
plusieurs fois par jour il est à
craindre que le petit cochon ne soit
jamais rappelé
[Musique]
l'ancien notaire je veux acheter la
petite ville avec some cuisine salle de
bains les binômes kepiro mais placard
aux balais et qui me coûte que 350 avec
les frais cela ferait ce un signe ici
[Musique]
pourquoi riez vous met donc le contrat
est signé je peux bien vous le dire la
maison est hantée têtes de bétail ont
été parquées la sorcière du placard aux
balais et et
essentiel ne vient que la belle reste
bien sage dans son bain seulement
attention si vous avez le malheur de
chanter sorciers et sorcières gros gare
de don delillo espèce d'idiot
vous aviez bien besoin de me chanter
dans le reee pareil maintenant je vais
plus penser qu'à ça
mais j'ai qu'à faire attention
oubliez cette chanson après tout c'est
le jour et je suis pas dans ma maison
sens hier 106 à prend garde à temps
derrière je suis dans ma maison mes deux
jours et je peux chanter sens hier 106,1
prend garde à temps derrière les mois
passèrent et une nuits s'il chantait
juste un petit bout de la chanson du
moment je la chante pas en entier la
sorcière plus rien contre moi
essentielle sorcières
[Musique]
sorcières censier reprend
ce ancien ressentir prend garde
[Musique]
s'enquiert sens hier en garde un sens
hier sens hier en garde à ton sens hier
106 enfants garde à ton père ancien
recensés après garde à temps derrière tu
te ça y est c'est chedjou et pourquoi
dois je prendre garde à mende arrière
bon je vous demande pardon madame tu
chanter ça sans y penser
samedi passé tu te manquer bien de moi
lorsque tu chantais pas petit chausson
jusqu'à l'avant dernière syllabe
mais ces pays c'est mon tour de m'amuser
pitié madame j'aime beaucoup les
sorcières ne me fait pas de mal mais je
te propose une épreuve
tu as trois jours pour me demander trois
choses possibles et si je ne peux te
donner une seule de ces trois sinon je
vais réfléchir à demain madame la
sorcière
bonjour bachir une méchante sorcière
vraiment porter tout ce qui pourrait me
sauver séduit demandé trois choses
impossibles si elle ne peut me donner
satisfaction
même une fois je serai sauver petit
monde à ta petite souris y interprète
qu'elle demande à tes poisson magique
sigean pas une idée oui petite souris
petite amie avec mes petits poissons et
tu auras du saulcy sensibilité pourpre
ou écoutent ce soir quand tu verras la
sorcière demande lui des bijoux
sorcières donne moi des bisous en
caoutchouc qui brillent comme des vrais
[Musique]
pour commencer ça n'a pas marché demande
à la forterre une branche de l'arbre
[Musique]
je veux une branche de l'arbre macaronis
qui puisse pousser dans mon jardin
[Musique]
ça n'a pas marché je suis perdu adieu
bachir n'a rien n'est perdu
c'est honteux se décourager comme sa
petite souris interroge encore les
poissons beaucoup
écoute c'est toi demande à la sorcière
qu'elle te donne la grenouille acheter
elle sera bien embarrassée parce que la
chronique à cheveux c'est elle
voici ce que tu te ra
[Musique]
donne moi la grenouille à cheveux je
veux la grenouille à cheveux tu peux pas
me les a donnés alors vas tu en voilà la
grenouille bachir sans ses cheveux toute
sa force était dans ses cheveux fait
depuis maintenant qu'une chronique
ordinaire qu'est ce qu'elle des petites
souris
elle ne veut pas très digne des chronos
[Musique]
il était une fois vieux roi qui régnait
sur une île une île magnifique ce roi
avait un jeune fille qui s'appelait le
prince henri marie françois guy pierre
antoine
c'était un nom bien long pour un si
petit prince
aussi quand il était enfant on
l'appelait ce blog
chaque matin au lieu de se débarbouiller
dans un lavabo ce qui est mortellement
ennuyeux le prince bleu va aller se
baigner nu dans la mer et chaque matin
il retrouvait une sirène avec laquelle
il doit depuis qu'il était petit quand
tu seras grand baie poudre à une belle
princesse qui aura deux jambes comme
tout le monde et non une ville en queue
de poisson
es-tu succédera au roi ton père n'en
disait le prince je ne voudrais que toi
aujourd'hui j'ai 15 ans je t'aime
toujours et je veux t'épouser cette fois
la sirène de vin poussive mais ces
mariages sont toujours malheureux tu
changerais et deux jambes pour une queue
de poisson
tu regretteras la vie mortelle la terre
est ton enfance mais moi je t'aime
disait le prince et je suis sûr de ne
rien regretter jamais
le père de blogs ayant appris que son
fils avait une sirène à la s'enquérir
auprès de l'aumônier du palais mais
c'est une catastrophe s'écrit à
l'aumônier les sirènes sont des démons
le prince en l'épousant deviendrait
ondins et n'aurait plus de gens mais une
queue de poisson
il ne pourrait jamais vous succéder il
faut les séparer
ton père de nous séparer blob ne crée
arias je suis immortel
si l'on nous sépare quand tu voudras me
retrouver mais toi dans un endroit où il
y à de l'eau douce ou salée
il te suffira alors de chanter un et
affronte ainsi ré de mamie je suis votre
ondins vous êtes ma vie le lendemain le
roi 20 à la plage accompagné de nombreux
notables dissimulant sous leurs habits
de cour des cordes des filets des
matraques et des révolvers aller à ce
signal ils se jetaient sur la sirène et
la prière dans leurs filets le prince
blog qui voulait la défendre fut
lui-même assailli avant d'avoir pu faire
un geste en porter moi ce monstre hurla
le roi est coupé lui la queue en
tranches pour la vendre au marché
quant à vous mon fils je vous envoie
chez mon cousin l'empereur de russie
loin de l'océan et de cet amour idiot
[Musique]
je t'aime rien font un sirène mamie je
suis votre mandat vous êtes ma vie
bonjour 13 belote tu m'aimes encore je
t'aime à rien font ainsi rennes mamie je
suis votre monde 1 vous êtes ma vie
bonjour prince vlad tu m'aimes encore
[Musique]
un jour l'empereur fit savoir au prince
blob que désormais ils n'auraient plus
le droit de se laver mon chef rosa
j'ai fait ce que j -p mais il est
impossible d'empêcher votre fils
d'évoquer cette semaine je vous le
renvoi et que dieu vous garde signé
nikita premier empereur de l'union le
roi l'aumônier allure cette lettre il
n'y avait plus qu'une solution
transformer le prince un timbre poste et
le coller au mur à l'endroit le plus sec
du palais afin que pose une goutte d'eau
me touche
abracadabra qui devient tout plein
abracadabra que devient tout petit
abracadabrante et devient papier
abracadabrant de papier collant petit
désormais le roi regarda le timbre de
près et demanda blog s'il voulait
toujours épouser sa sirène
oui je le veux toujours répondait une
voix de papier les jours les semaines
les mois passèrent oui je le veux
répondait toujours le timbre blob
[Musique]
puis gilles utah un cyclone venant de la
mer mais le palais royal était bien bâti
et pas une goutte d'eau ne parvint au
bureau du plan physique eu la guerre et
quand le roi et la reine remontèrent de
la cad le palais commencèrent le roi
affole et pénétra dans son bureau un
verre d'eau à la main les flammes dans
ces de toutes parts le roi embrassa le
timbre en pleurant sois heureux mon
petit fils voulu jeter le verre d'eau
sur le timbre est le timbre avait
disparu une larme du roi l'avait mouillé
blob avait enfin rejoint c'est si vrai
[Musique]
peu après une terrible nouvelle la
flotte ennemie étaient signalés les
bateaux avancée mais soudain autour de
la mer se mit à onduler elle se
remplissaient de choses bizarres une
nageoire map temps une fuite hors du
nouvel ouverte la flotte ennemie
semblait voguer sur une mer de 9 au bout
d'une demi heure la flotte ennemie et
est entièrement détruite
ben lobb et la sirène sauver le royaume
le roi était heureux ou du moins presque
heureux la paix régnait sur l'île mais
lille restait sans prince et le roi sans
enfant si ce n'est que cela pense à la
sirène je vais tout arranger baignez
vous sur la plage d'état le roi avec sa
majesté la reine
quand vous verrez un poisson d'argent
qui viendra jouer autour de vous laisser
le faire
n'ayez pas peur de lui et dans huit
jours vous aurez un petit garçon une
semaine plus tard ils arrêtent un petit
prince
oui tout cela se passait il ya bien
longtemps aujourd'hui le prince blob est
toujours un nom d'un ses parents eux
sont morts bien entendu mais leur petit
enfant règne encore sur l'île heureuse
et aucun flotte ennemie n'ose venir les
attaquer
[Musique]
il était une fois dans un village une
jeune fille qui s'appelait mireille et
qui aimait beaucoup les oeufs à la coque
ce matin là elle était justement à table
avec un 9/20 sont copiés et s'apprêtait
à l'ouvrir avec une petite cuillère au
premier coup de cuillère la maison se
mit à trembler au second coup de
cuillère
la maison s'est mis à bouger au
troisième coupe toute la maison sauter
en l'air et la tête d'un géant à paris
et je voudrais tu es pouget pose moi
décorateur je te répondrais que ce
qu'elle veut dur pour la jeune et par
une réponse cependant le géant finissait
de sortir de terre et tirait sur
d'immenses chaussettes rouges lorsque
surgit le curé du village très fâché
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais en
voilà des manières ce pour mireille sa
maison tout démoli mais ce n'est pas
grave
le bâtiment suma partie
par la vertu de mes chaussettes moule
que la maison de mireille soir bon c'est
bien mais maintenant vous en une minute
j'ai quelque chose à demander je
voudrait épouser murray mais c'est
impossible vous êtes trop grand vous ne
pourriez pas entrer dans l'église
mais comment faire pour un petit su mais
écoutez vous vous mecs en pratique l
erreur de ma part le grand souk siennois
revenir dans un an et mireille sera prêt
pour bouger plus
attention pas plus longtemps ou pub est
il votre grand sorcier chinois ou chine
[Musique]
ce qui en chinois signifie c'est bien
vous le grand sorcier
[Musique]
ce qui veut dire oui c'est moi et à
l'heure je voudrais rapetisse eu alors
le géant rentra dans une grande colère
et se met à crier très fort je te coach
coach ou cocteau ce qui veut dire est ce
que tu te moques de moi et maintenant
fais-moi rapetissé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où d'habitude votre sorcier breton trois
mois plus tard le géant arriva en
bretagne il eût fallu un mois encore
pour trouver le sorcier bretons
excusez moi pourriez-vous me faire
rapetisser plus est très exigent
on peut je suis trompé tu nies bibi
mais cela ne suffit pas je dois devenir
aussi petit qu'un homme impossible j'ai
plus de pression
écoutez vous mais sa tactique est elle
est donc de ma part voir le pape de rome
et où habitent ils ce denier données est
à rome
[Musique]
un mois plus tard le géant arriva à rome
mais il fallait encore quinze jours pour
trouver la maison du pain je veux
devenir aussi petit qu'un homme
ma fiancée m'attend dans quinze jours si
je suis trop grand jeu ne pourrait pas
entrer dans l'église pour l'épouser
comme cette hausse 1 je ne suis pas
sorcier mais vous m sympathique
j'ai vu fait qu'il qui soude pour allo
ici la femme vierge qui est à l'appareil
chez moi la pape diouf est ici 1 0 qui
voudrait devenir aussi pythie kent homes
ou su marier ce qui dit 'est-ce qu'il
n'a pas des chaussettes rouges votre g 1
et bien dites lui qu'il donne c'est
chaud ce cas la blanchisseuse et qu'ils
aillent se tremper les deux pieds dans
la merde en invoquant il verra bien ce
qui lui arrivera et quand je prévois
qu'il aura des ennuis dit l'icg ensuite
il pourra faire trois voeux qui seront
exaucés sur le champ mori mori morts
bonjour madame je viens chercher la
paire de chaussettes rouges de trois
mètres de long vous voulez dire les deux
sacs de couchage ce sont des chaussettes
moi quand je vois une chaussette dans
laquelle je peux entrer tout entière
j'appelle ça un sac de couchage et bien
donné l'émoi
mais qu'est ce que je vais devenir
je ne suis plus j'ai un et sans mes
chaussettes rouges
je ne suis plus rien du tout
[Musique]
si seulement elle pouvait se réduire à
matin c'était son premier voeu qui se
réaliser mais comme il n'était plus j'ai
un
il ne pouvait revenir à pied au village
de mireille et je n'ai plus que 15 jours
pour retrouver ma fiancée
si je pouvais être près d'elle je sais
tout ce que tu as fait pour moi et
aujourd'hui je t'aime dans six mois nous
nous marierons dans six mois seulement
mais il pensa soudain qu'il lui restait
un troisième feu à faire et il dit à
haute voix que ce soit le meilleur
depuis ce jour ils vivre heureux et il y
aura t il une opel et beaucoup d'enfants
[Musique]
il ya très longtemps à l'époque des
romains rivet un roi barbare quand ce
roi eut un fils une bonne fée lui
apparut et lui dit tout fils est
immortel il ne mourra jamais il
deviendra un grand guerrier et il fera
de grandes choses mais tout cela à une
condition laquelle c'est que tu lui
donnes le nom de lustucru aux actes une
hésitation car même pour un barbare le
nom de tulle lustucru est ridicule
cependant il accepte le prince lustucru
grandi et le roi son père l'envoyaient à
rome parfaire son éducation
comme il était intelligent il était le
premier par tous
ou plutôt ils auraient dû l'être ses
maîtres ne lui donnait jamais la
première place parce que pour rien au
monde il n'aurait voulu dire ou écrire
premier lustucru le pauvre lustucru fut
donc un éternel second
mais il se dit je suis pourtant meilleur
que tous les autres
mais cela ne suffit pas il me faut
accompli
quelque chose d'énorme voyons tiens je
vais conquérir la coupe seulement la
gaule c'était un gros morceau et il lui
si tu cru ne pouvait la conquérir tout
seul il lui fallait une armée aux 20
jours dans les rues de rome
un mendiant l'arête a pitié monsieur
donnez moi quelque chose
voyons les aventures les voyages et les
batailles
ça ne te fait pas peur or non monsieur
en ce cas tu entres à mon service
tu vas me soulever une armée et nous
allons conquérir l'amour comment
t'appelles-tu jules et bien jules suis
moi c'est ainsi que jules césar demain
le lieutenant de lustucru et calvet de
hilde vers une armée et à l'air
combattre le roi de la gaule qui n'était
autre que vercingétorix
mais les gaulois qui était courageux et
actif manquer terriblement de discipline
et finalement vercingétorix dû
reconnaître sa défaite et se rendit un
lustucru celui-ci écrivit toute
l'histoire dans un livre dont il confia
le manuscrit à jules césar en lui disant
rapporté ce livre aux romains leur
d'irak lustucru a conquis la gaule
arrivé à rome j'ai le césar dit aux
sénateurs romains mois
jules césar je viens de conquérir la
gaule
maintenant vous allez me nommé empereur
sinon je lance mon armée contre vous et
les romains le nommèrent empereur le
pauvre lustucru compris qu'une fois de
plus on lui avait volé la première place
le temps passa
et lustucru chutent encore de grandes
choses c'est lui qui devant clovis casal
le vase de soissons c'est lui qui sonna
du corps à roncevaux du guesclin c'était
lustucru jeanne d'arc c'était encore
lustucru et c'était pas napoléon qui
traversaient le pont d'arcole à pied non
c'était toujours lustucru et malgré
toutes ses actions d'éclat son nom
restaient inconnues dans l'histoire
complètement découragé il s'en alla
trouver la grande sorcière de la rue
mouffetard
bonjour madame la sorcière voyez-vous
jeu suivant braves est immortel
cependant personne ne sait que six mois
lustucru qui est fait de si grandes
choses avec un nom pareil
vous n'avez qu'une seule chose à faire
pour être fanny s'est dit prêt dans une
chanson
[Musique]
alors il s'installa dans un petit
village où il acheta une maison et toute
la journée
il regarda sa voisine d'en face une
certaine madame michel louis qui vivait
avec son chat à france 2 la regarder et
il en devint amoureux alors un jour il
acheta un bouquet et a lâché sa voisine
parce que vous désirez et bien voilà je
suis votre voisin et je désire vous
épousez pas possible mais je vous
connais à peine comment vous
appelez-vous m'appelle lustucru je n'ai
pas envie
avec un nom pareil c'est ridicule aux
yeux de toupie et une fois de plus le
pauvre lustucru été victime de son nom
mais cette fois il était amoureux et il
ne se tape pas pour battu or un soir il
a perçu dans la rue le chat de sa
voisine mini mini mini mini il le saisit
l emporte un bain le lendemain la mère
michel à sa fenêtre se lamentait où l on
ça
moi j'ai perdu mon petit minet mais non
vous ne l'avez pas perdu il est chez moi
je viens de chercher tout de suite je
n'ai pas dit que je vous le vend des je
ne peux pas vivre sans mon chien et bien
alors épouse et moi et je vous le
rendrai et si je refuse je le mange
c'est entendu je vous épouser merci
madame michèle au moment où les nouveaux
mariés sortaient de l'église
les enfants du pays se mirent à chanter
vous aviez atteint 10 cents chats qui
crie par l'architecte lui rabat c'est la
palestine qui a grandi à l'homélie ce ne
fut pas depuis ce temps le père lui
c'est rue vie parfaitement heureux dans
son petit village avec sa femme et le
petit chat
[Musique]
dans un village vivait deux frères l'un
était riche l'autre pauvre le riz
j'étais célibataire
le pauvre était marié leriche ne
travaillait pas le pauvre était ouvrier
agricole il n'avait pas de maison mais
vivait avec sa femme chez le fermier qui
l'employait tandis que le riche lui
avait une grande et belle maison
le pauvre est gentil avec tout le monde
aussi des gens du village là mais bien
le riche lui était avare de sorte que
les gens ne l'aiment et guerre mais avec
l'hiver
le pauvre ne veut plus de travail il
avait demandé à son frère l'hospitalité
leriche voulu bien les bergers avec sa
femme mais à la condition qu'ils soient
couchés dès 9 heures du soir
le pauvre accepta et le jour même il
s'installait avec sa femme pendant trois
mois ils vécurent tounsi ils prenaient
leur repas ensemble et après le dîner
sitôt la table desservi le pauvre et sa
femme monter ce coup chez le riche lui
payait très tard jusqu'à une heure
avancée de la nuit
casse pour faire ton frère site hors
effet ce que vous allez chez lui
mais la femme voulait pourtant savoir un
soir elle descendit doucement l'escalier
pieds nus et sans lumière
elle s'approcha sans faire du bruit et
elle lit son beau frère assis devant une
petite boîte en fer d'où il tirait des
pièces d'or qu'il empile leurs montagnes
et dit à son mari
ton frère raconte de l'or et pourquoi
point c'est son or près tout un matin
la femme du pauvre des 110 pour un hymne
du feu et faire le café le riche étaient
encore couchés
et elle s'aperçut soudain il admis
[Musique]
en
m
qu'est ce que t'en après le couple a
lâché le notaire leriche n'ayant pas
d'enfant tous ces biens revenait aux
pauvres mais il restait la boîte de
pièces d'or
un soir qu'il l'a cherchée dans toute la
maison fantôme du riche leur a paru
allez vous en disiez vous n'aurez pas
mono effrayer le parti ils achetèrent
une petite maison et vécurent à l'abri
du besoin
plus tard il ya un petit garçon et
l'année d'après une petite fille
tous les dimanches après midi il allait
se promener on n'est pas du côté du
cimetière
surtout entre et jamais dans la maison
de vente ou joe pia il se fâchait mais
voilà qu'un beau soir de printemps les
enfants vivent surpris par l'orage il
pleuvait fort très fort
le ciel était noir et plein d claire
entrons dans cette maison le petit
garçon avait bien reconnu la maison de
l'oncle mais il faisait tellement
mauvais qu'il entre air ils trouvèrent
mali se déshabillait récent dormir il
fut réveillé par une grosse voix
qu'est-ce qu'on veut d'ici pas dans le
dieu je note que pour le mettre à l'abri
y est colabor qui êtes vous lorsqu'il
dire leur nom le fantôme s'écria alors
comme ça vous êtes mes neveux
oui mon oncle à je comprends tout
maintenant c'est votre père qui vous en
voyez ici pour m'espionner et me pour me
voler mon corps doit vous vous trompez
mon nom je vous assure c'est pas fin à
l'eau sortait l'issue les deux enfants
allaient sortir quand le fantôme lézard
état
où allez vous voyez bien qu'ils pleurent
encore rester ici on est chacun une
couverture approchez-vous échauffez vous
alors le petit garçon s'est endormi mais
un éclat de rire réveil
c'était sa petite soeur car l'oncle
pierre s'était endormi aussi et la
petite fille en avait profité pour
monter sur ses genoux et traversant le
corps impalpable du fantôme elle s'était
assise dans l' oncle pierre ça la
faisait rire donc le pierre réveiller à
l'instant regardaient d'un air
bouleversé la petite fille assise danse
c'est donc vrai
je suis un fantôme
denis
demain matin vous donnerez ça à vos
parents
le lendemain il faisait grand jour et
l'oncle avait disparu
les enfants rentraient chez leurs
parents avec la boîte pleine de pièces
d'or il ya des gens qui prétendent que
cette nuit là les enfants n'avait fait
qu'un rêve
mais ce qu'il y a certains c'est que
depuis ce jour le fantôme de l'oncle
pierre n'est plus jamais revenu dans la
vieille maison
[Musique]
à
il était une fois un petit garçon qui
s'appelait bachir il avait un papa qui
s'appelait saïd est une poupée qui
s'appelait scooby doo
saïd était un bon papa et scooby 12
n'était pas une poupée comme les autres
elle avait le pouvoir magique de voir le
passé et l'avenir
il suffisait pour cela de lui bander les
yeux
un beau matin il n'a pas ça des lots
j'ai pas d'argent
et puis l'année prochaine tu auras grand
dîner il sera trop petit vélo bachir
n'insista pas mais le soir il demanda à
scooby doo dix mois tant pis c'est tout
quand elle jure un vélo je vois un vélo
mais pas avant un an ou deux au but
avant ne te désole pas je vais partir et
dans ce nom je reviendrai avec tomber
l'eau cependant j'ai besoin de quelque
chose comme tu ne seras pas là pour me
bander les yeux
il me faut une paire de lunettes noires
d'accord et scooby doo s'en fout
[Musique]
elle arriva dans un grand port communeau
est ce que tu sais faire je sais dire le
passé bien venir et les choses cachées
vous avez une fois moindre avec un
ensemble au vous avez une femme à
singapour avec deux enfants jaune
vous avez une femme à dakar avec six ans
c'est assez il voit plutôt le temps
qu'il fera demain il fera très mauvais
temps et vous ne pourrez pas sortir du
port et bien parions si demain il fait
mauvais temps
je termine avec moi une idée de roubaix
je te laisse ici est en effet le
lendemain la tempête ce lot
[Musique]
l'ue a gagné poubelle
je t'emmène mais il faut me payer pour
acheter le vélo de bachir c'était
convenu et c'est ainsi que scooby doo
fit le tour du monde en annonçant le
temps sans jamais se tromper
jusqu'au jour où et quelques instants
plus tard dix mois coupé quel temps fera
t-il demain je peux pas vous dire
monsieur marin je n'y ai pas volées
amène à lunettes ou pas lunettes idoines
dire le temps qui foirent 3 que de payer
rien faire il fera plutôt bon hélas le
lendemain des lots un gros nuage surgi à
l'horizon le marin dorin furieux et
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce que je veux devenir ici nos
pauvres vaches qui attend son bus hall a
minima ce requin valletoux bonjour
poupée bonjour litres que cette perle
megève si je pouvais trouver quelqu'un
qui me débarrasse de cette saleté je te
l'enac si tu veux à l'abandon je peux
acheter cinq ou six vélos à bachy ouvre
toi toute grande et là c'est fini
merci huîtres commente il faire pour
rentrer chez moi tu n'as qu'à te
balancer d'un pied sur l'autre leur cas
sera malade il fera ce que tu voudras en
effet au bout de deux minutes
il eut le hockey à l'eau c'est fini le
dos ne reçoit pas tort de ma nourriture
avait c'est ou paris commentant la scène
terminus tout le monde descend
les fils et que je te revois plus nager
dans de l'eau douche je suis déshonoré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papa saïd je suis très content la perle
fut vendu un bijoutier et bachir eu un
très joli vélo
[Musique]
il y avait une fois dans le quartier des
gobelins à paris
une vieille sorcière affreusement
vieille et l'aide mais qui aurait bien
voulu passer pour la plus belle fille du
monde
un beau jour en lisant le journal des
sorcières
elle tomba sur le communiqué suivant
mada
vous qui êtes vieille laide vous
deviendrez jeune et jolie et pour cela
manger une petite fille à la sauce
tomate
or il y avait dans ce même quartier une
petite fille qui s'appelait nadia
c'était la fille aînée de papa saïd qui
tenait l'épicerie buvette de la rue
broca
[Musique]
il faut que je mange nadia se dit la
sorcière
un beau jour que la diète est sorti pour
aller chez le volailler une vieille
marchand dollar et à bonjour ma petite
fille tu veux de la viande
ah non madame je viens acheter un poulet
zut pense à la sorcière
le lendemain la sorcière sous déguiser
en marchand de volailles
bonjour petite tu m'achètes un poulet ah
non madame aujourd'hui je veux de la
viande
lui pense à la sorcière le troisième
jour déguisé à nouveau l vander la fois
de la viande et de la volaille dose
journalière qu'est ce que tu peux tu
vois aujourd'hui the band ou du boeuf du
mouton du poulet du lapin oui mais moi
je veux du poisson crottes ans à la
sorcière et bien puisque c'est comme ça
demain matin je deviendrai à moi tout
seul toutes les marchands de la rue
mouffetard est en effet le jour suivant
toutes les marchandes
il y en avait exactement 267
nadia vin comme à l'ordinaire s'approcha
sans méfiance d'un élémentaire de
légumes pour acheter cette fois les
haricots verts le marchand de la saisie
par le poignet l'enleva est au format
dans le tiroir caisse
mais heureusement nadia avait un petit
frère qui s'appelait bachir
voyant que sa grande soeur mais rentrait
pas bachir se dit c'est sûrement la
sorcière qui l'a prise
il faut que j'aille il a délivré il pris
sa guitare et son furieux goudard en la
voyant arriver les 267 marchande qui
était la sorcière se mirent à crier où
vas-tu comme ça bachir scheer ferma les
yeux et répondit je suis un pauvre
musicien aveugle et je voudrais gagner
quelques sous et chanter une chanson qui
s'appelle nadia où es tu n'at on pas
celle-là chan dans une autre mais j'en
sais pas d'autre alors chante là tout
tout tout bas c'est entendu et bachir se
mit à chanter tout beau
na bien où est elle répond que jetables
car je ne te vois plus
- forme moins fort crièrent les 267
marchande
q nous casse les oreilles
mais bachir continuer de chanter quand
tout à coup une petite voix lui répondit
achir bachir des livres moi ou la
sorcière me tuera en entendant ces mots
bachir ouvrit les yeux et les 267
marchande sauter sur lui en criant c'est
un faux ou aveugle c'est un format bugs
mais agir qui était courageux brandit sa
petite guitare et à soma d'un coup la
marchande la plus proche elle tombe
raide et les 266 autres avec pour la
seconde fois la petite voix lui répondit
bachir bachir des livres moi ou la
sorcière me tuera cette fois il n'y
avait plus de doute la voix venait de
chez la marchande de légumes
il entra dans la boutique et il essayait
d'ouvrir le tiroir caisse
bachir bachir des livres moi ou la
sorcière me tuera il tiroirs était trop
dure et bachir travailler et pendant ce
temps les 267 marchande se réveillait se
garde bien d'ouvrir les yeux
elle restait les yeux fermés et elle
s'approchait en rampant de la boutique
comme bachir épuisés ne savait plus que
faire
il vit passer un grand marin tout jeune
très costaud qui descendait la bonjour
marin peux-tu me porter ce tiroir caisse
jusque chez nous ma soeur est enfermé
dedans
et qu'est ce que j'aurais comme
récompense tu auras l'argent et moi
j'aurai ma soeur d'accord bachir souleva
le tiroir caisse et allait le passé aux
marins quand la marchande de légumes qui
s'était approché la trappe à part à pied
et se mit à glapir abri dans je te tiens
scheer perdit l'équilibré et laissa
échapper le tiroir caisse
celui ci était très lourd tomba en plein
sur la tête de la marchande et de ce
coup là les 267 marchande sûrs tout en
même temps le crâne fracassé
cette fois la sorcière était morte est
bien morte
sous le choc le tiroir s'ouvrit et nadia
enceinte elle embrasse à son petit frère
le remercia et tous de retour nerfs chez
leurs parents pendant que le marin
ramassait l'argent de la sorcière
[Musique]
je
il était une fois une paire de
chaussures qui étaient mariés ensemble
elle habitait une belle boîte en carton
où elle était enroulé dans du papier de
soie la chaussure droite qui était le
monsieur s'appelait nicolas et la
chaussure gauche qui était la dame
s'appelait tina
elle s'y trouvait parfaitement heureuse
et elle espérait bien que cela durera t
mais voilà qu'un beau matin on voit une
très jolie paire chère madame je pense
qu'elle vous iront très bien
c'est ainsi que nicolas et tina
marchèrent toute une journée sans se
voir l'un l'autre le soir enfin il se
retrouvait au fond d'un placard c'est
toi tina oui c'est moi nicolas à quel
bonheur que tu croyais perdu
moi aussi j'étais au pied droit
j'étais au pied gauche ah je comprends
toutes les fois que tu étais en avant
moi j'étais en arrière
et lorsque depuis en arrière moi j'étais
en avant c'est pour cela que nous ne
pouvions pas nous voir mais cette ville
à voir recommencer chaque jour je le
crains cet affreux écoute puisque je
suis toujours à droite et toi toujours à
gauche
chaque fois que j'avancerai je ferai en
même temps un petit écart de ton côté
comme ça
nous nous tirons bonjour d'accord
d'accord ainsi qu'il le sorte que le
jour suivant
très inquiète la dame à la consulter un
médecin pas de cachette de temps je ne
sais pas ce que j'ai je me fais décroche
tiens moi même mes pieds droits
franchement talon gauche
cela fait donc mais c'est ok c'est très
grave si cela continue magnum
il faudra vous couper le pied droit
voici une ordonnance
donnez-moi dix mille francs anciens pour
la consultation et revenez me voir
demain tu entendu ce qu'a dit le docteur
si on coupe le pied droit de la dame l2
jettera nous serons séparés pour
toujours et compte puisque je suis à
gauche
demain c'est moi qui ferai un écart à
droite chaque fois que j'avancerai
d'accord et le deuxième jour de plus en
plus inquiète la dame retourna chez son
médecin
docteur docteur maintenant c'est vrai
qu'à gauche qui accroche mais c'est de
plus en plus grand format d'un si cela
continue il faudra vous coupez les deux
pieds revoici une ordonnance dinars si
l'on couple et de pied de la dame
car nous devenir je n'ose pas y penser
et pourtant je t'aime dit là aussi
nicolas chaudun je voudrais ne jamais
quitter non plus il pouvait ainsi dans
l'obscurité de leur placard sans se
douter que la dame qui les avaient
achetés se promenait dans le couloir
en plateau
elle entendit
elle comprit tout à c'est donc ça ce
n'est pas moi qui suis malade
ce sont mes chaussures qui s'aiment pas
comme ça
là dessus elle je parle a pas tort sur
tous les médicaments qu'elle avait
acheté et à plat sa femme de ménage
pepita vous voyez cette paire de
chaussures je ne les mettraient plus
mais je veux les garder quand même alors
cyril et bien qu'elle soit toujours
brillante et surtout ne les séparait
jamais l'une de l'autre
alors la dame a des fois des indécis
chaussures sont les maîtres tu avais une
quinzaine de jours
quand elle les aura oublié je lis pour
lui l'arrêt et quinze jours plus tard
elle les vols à et se limite au pied
mais un soir dans l'escalier de service
nicolas et tina voulurent s'embrasser et
badaboum moteur hemi à ses chaussures
elles sont sous le soleil je ne la vois
plus les maîtres je vais les donner à ma
nièce la pépite à la nièce qui était
boiteux passé presque toutes ces
journées assise sur une chaise les pieds
joints et les chaussures étaient
heureuses car elles étaient le plus
souvent côte à côte
cela durera longtemps mais un soir dean
a dit à nicolas
sans ma semelle qui devient fip
je vais bientôt être père ne fait pas ça
si on nous jette
nous allons être séparés pour toujours
c'est bien je ne peux pas m'empêcher de
vieillir qu'allons nous devenir
c'est pas si seulement j'étais sûr de
pas de quitter approche toi prends ma
bride avec la tienne de toute façon ne
seront jamais séparés c'est ainsi
qu'ensemble ils furent jetés à la
poubelle et abandonné dans un terrain
vague
il y restèrent ensemble jusqu'au jour où
un petit garçon et une petite fille qui
passait par là
allili regarde les chaussures à son bras
dessus bras dessous c'est qu'elles sont
mariés ensemble
ada puisqu'elle son mari ensemble avant
faire leur voyage de noces à les
dissocier
c'est ainsi que nicolas et tina qui
n'attendait plus rien de l'existence
sûrs quand même un beau voyage de noces
[Musique]
il était une fois une fée adoré de tous
qui vivaient dans une source
et puis un jour le curé fille dresser en
cet endroit une grande croix de pierre
pendant 15 cents en plus de personne
n'entendit parler de la fait même les
curés cessèrent de croire en elle
patience un jour cette croix tombera et
de nouveau je serai libre
un jour deux hommes passèrent près de la
source
ils décidèrent de l'utiliser pour le
ravitaillement de l'être
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que l'a fait se retrouve à
un beau jour dans une canalisation
aboutissants talent robinet cuivre d'une
famille ouvrière comprenant le père la
mère et deux grandes filles une fois
l'aînée des fillettes et gourmande et
mal élevés se leva sur le coup de 2
heures du matin pour aller tremper son
doigt dans un pot de confiture et le les
chats après quoi elle eu soif
mais voilà qu'au lieu dos il s'échappa
du rebut une toute petite bonne femme
avec des haines de lille
bonjour martel bonjour madame veux tu
être gentille martine denoyelle de
confiture quand elle vit que la fée
était bien habillé avec des ailes de
libellule et une baguette magique lui
dit mais certainement madame on remercie
martine je vais te faire un don à chaque
mot que tu diras il te sortira de la
bouche
une perle ben ça alors
si elle disait des mots plus long un
gros tir est peut-être
m
o o
10 constitutionnel les personnes en
surpoids plus grosse mais plus allongée
et d'une forme plus biscornues en pis le
tout face sur l'autre fortune effet geek
oui
c'est tout
alors les parents obligèrent martin à ne
plus dire que des gros mots au dessus du
saladier
[Musique]
ouais
et
à
[Musique]
et
à
[Rires]
m
allez encore vous êtes merveilleuse
restons ensemble
voulez vous nous serons heureux
maintenant matip parlant de choses
sérieuses ce soit quand je reviendrai je
veux que la grande soupe hier je vois
plein de grosses perles
[Musique]
la jeune soeur de martin qui était sage
et bonne n'avait pas la moindre envie de
rencontrer la fée du robinet je n'irai
pas dans la cuisine je n'irai pas dans
la cuisine et ré pas dans la cuisine bat
pour finir elle ya là en espérant que la
fin ne sortirait pas trop qui est bonne
donne moi un peu de confiture
merci bien je n'ai pas besoin de vos
dons
vous avez fait le malheur de minceur et
bien puisque vous êtes ip aimable et
vous donne pour donc à chaque mot que
vous direz il vous sortira de la bouche
un serpent
[Musique]
[Rires]
voulez-vous me suivre dans la salle de
bain branchez-vous bien sûr la baignoire
et maintenant petit amour maman à
présent la petite marie edith mois une
paroles méchantes
que faut-il faire docteur mon cher
monsieur
j'ai bien l'honneur de vous demander la
main de votre fille c'est ainsi que
marie épousa le jeune médecin qui
travaillait à l'institut pasteur à la
fabrication des sérums antivenimeux ce
dernier fut très bon pour elles à
quelques temps delà la fée du robinet
voulu savoir ce qu'il était advenu des
deux filles est elle apparue à leurs
parents elle les interrogeaient les
parents la myrte au courant ma pauvre
fait découragés se dit en elle-même il
faut que je trouve un enchanteur puis
sache comment le fait du robinet dessina
donc un enchanteur
a pourvu qu'ils l'aiment et elle s'est
mise à chanter un chanteur plus couleur
des yeux
je t'ai dessinée veux tu met d'accord
avant tout je vais ôter leurs dons à
marie ainsi qu'à martin le lendemain
martin aurait cessé de cracher des
perles et le jeune homme à l'air doux la
chasse a alors elle revint chez ses
parents et puis désormais douce est
bonne le même jour marie cessa de grh et
des serpents l'enchanteur l à fait
disparu
ils ne font presque plus de miracles ils
sont très très prudent
[Musique]
il était une fois une patate une
vulgaire patate comme nous en voyons
tous les jours mais dévoré d'ambition
le rêve de sa vie était de devenir
frites et c'est probablement ce qui
serait arrivé si
[Musique]
m
regarde comme tu es belle ok alors je
ressemble un bon savoir puisque tu le
prends comme ça je les paie fort bien
fréquenté il ya ici des tas de gens
intéressants qui qui est cette personne
qui ressemble à une poêle à frire
bonjour madame la poêle à frire
vous êtes bien aimable je ne sais pas ce
qu est une poêle à frire
mais je ne suis pas n'importe qui je
m'appelle guitare et bien moi je
m'appelle pommes de terre mais vous
pouvez m'appeler patate
car je vous considère dès aujourd'hui
comme mon ami j'avais été choisi à cause
de ma beauté pour devenir
l'état valeur le petit garçon de la
maison m'a complètement à l'eau ne
pleurait pas mais vous êtes encore très
bien
depuis cela vous permet de parler ça
c'est vrai mais vous comment êtes vous
venu ici au mois j'étais l'ami d'un
jeune garçon qui même à tendrement me
prenait dans ses bras me gratter votre
ajouté deschamps ce n'est un jour il est
revenu avec une étrangère vulgaire qu'il
avait ensorcelé
je suis sûr qu'il ne l'aimait pas
d'ailleurs il n'avait pas confiance en
elle il la tenait attaché avec une
laisse moi quand j'ai vu ça j'ai préféré
partir
[Musique]
comme c'est beau je savais que nous
étions fait pour nous comprendre
d'ailleurs plus je vous regarde plus je
trouve que vous ressemblez à une poêle à
ça c'est pas ordinaire une patate et une
guitare qui parle si je sais me prendre
ma fortune est fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est le directeur
qu'est ce que vous voulez monsieur le
directeur
j'ai une patate qui parle un bain vous
êtes souvent de vie et une guitare qui
répond non je suis pas sous écoute est
allé parler toutes les deux ben vous
avez bien quelque chose à vous le dire
dites moi mon habit vous payer ma tête
sortez maintenant à mais quand elles
sont toutes seules
alors c'est vrai faut parler toutes les
deux et inutile de vous taire je vous ai
entendu dommage j'avais une belle
proposition à vous faire une proposition
artistique une proposition artistique
eh bien oui vous allez travailler
vous allez devenir fêter j'aimerais être
frites pas être free être mangé avec
votre talent ça se mange des frites
s'il en est ainsi j'aime mieux de venir
vous l'êtes le soir de la première fut
un énorme succès parmi les spectateurs
se trouvaient le sultan de pétaouchnok
qui s'est pris immédiatement la patte ap
[Musique]
vous ou le monsieur le directeur veut
épouser la pata mais voyons de bonnes
personnes
alors je vous la chair or vous me fait
beaucoup de pub et bien je vous l'achète
voit-on de diama un seul do do si vous
voulez ils n'ont pas non plus le
lendemain le sultan repartait dans son
sultanat en emmenant la patate et aussi
la guitare car les deux amis ne voulait
pas se quitter
[Musique]
une semaine après les journaux
publiaient les photos du mariage du
sultan et de la patate